Alright guys, so in this video we are going to talk about breaker blocks. It is another entry pattern that you can use
It is very powerful. So what essentially is breaker block?
When you have a lower low
lower high lower low and a market structure shift
So when you had lower low
lower high
lower low, the last lower low
And the last candle of that lower low right here
Is your breaker block. So you have lower low lower high lower low and
Market structure shift if you have another small lower low here like lower low lower high small lower high lower low
And then market structure shift then that would be your breaker block. So
The first candle right here
First candle before this move or you could say the last candle
before this last lower low is
Your breaker block and if there is some
Fairbody gap here, then that breaker block becomes very strong
However, if there is no fairbody gap, you can still take entry from this level, okay?
But if there's fairbody gap then that becomes even better price comes back here and boom
Similarly, you have higher high high low higher high market structure shift
this
last candle
Before the move to the upside and then market structure shift. So you have higher high high low
The last candle of the higher low is your breaker block, okay?
Price comes back here if there is fairbody gap right here
You can literally take your entry from here instead of looking for entry from the extreme fairbody gap
What you can do as an entry model you can look for entry here
so a lot of people asking me we miss sometimes we miss the trade and
this is how you can
minimize the risk of missing the trade
Yes, your stop loss going to be big or you can just put your stop above the breaker block
But trust me you're gonna lose so just put it above the fair extreme fairbody gap
So this right here is your breaker block
Let me show you an example if I can find it
Um, I drew it somewhere here. Where is it? Where is it? Where is it?
Mm-hmm. Okay, I think I I deleted it. So I'm gonna pause the video find it and then come back